foreign
and Netflix fans I am Guillermo del Toro
this is Mike Pinocchio
[Music]
there's a valuable difference between
stop-motion as an art form and digital
stop-motion in the early days where you
have the moire and the flicker of fur
and fabric even the atmospheric dust on
the sets and the imperfection of it was
so gorgeous to look at because he told
you how the thing was done
and I really wanted this movie to land
in a way that had the expressiveness and
the material nature of a handmade piece
of Animation an artisanal beautiful
exercise and carving painting sculpting
but it had the sophistication of
movement that research on Rigs and
puppetry making have taken us through
in terms of scale we use different size
of puppets for different needs this is
our Pinocchio to interact with the
cricket in order for him to be the right
size we need the Cricket and the
shoulder of Pinocchio talking to him
whispering in his ear laying close to
him so we use this big Pinocchio this
small cricket and then in certain shots
we use this small Penelope
Pinocchio is a tale that has lived
through the centuries
fabled very close to my heart and we are
very sure that this incarnation
is a particularly beautiful one
[Music]